all right good afternoon everyone
welcome to our latest webinar on NCBI
keys we've been talking about API keys
now for a while and it's been an
interesting journey for all of us we've
certainly learned a lot from talking
with you about keys and your use cases
and requirements and we're now in us
prepared to move forward with
implementation if you haven't had a
chance to look at our previous webinars
the most recent of which was back in
April of this year I'd encourage you to
go to our webinar site on main NCBI
homepage click on learn and click on
webinars and you'll find them there also
in the YouTube site now to catch up on
what we've talked about before I'm not
going to repeat all that information so
that's all available to you
I do want to do a quick review just to I
make sure we're at least on the basic
page that's similar of understanding
talk about the current sandbox that's in
place now for you to test these keys
really hammer home what's happening now
what the status is now what you should
expect and then what's coming the
testing periods I'll talk more about and
finally the full release of functional
keys in production so this is just to
remind you what the e-utilities do the
point of that slide really is just to
confirm the fact that this is only
applying to utilities it does not apply
to any other api's and NCBI such as the
blasts API or the variation services API
is a other API so that we have just
effects the e-utilities but it does
affect all of them search summary fetch
link post cetera and the idea is that
these are unique strings that identify
you the user or a particular piece of
software to our API keys need to be
included in every API request and they
are attached to an NCBI account one
keeper account so the idea is that with
a key we will enable you to have
increased access to the servers and
exchange for some information about
usage about what's happening with the
servers and with with your software the
we'll help us all make these API is more
stable and reliable they are freely
available to the public but free without
any regulation leads to overuse and
abuse at times and we really like to
have them be available 24/7 for everyone
fairly and openly and so establishing
keys lets us monitor that and make sure
that we can provide that level of
service for everyone you get a key very
simply by going to an NCBI account so if
you may know this as a my NCBI accounts
all the same thing you go there you log
in and there will be a button create an
API key on the main page of your account
click it and you get a key in just a
string you copy it you put it in your
code
- simple as that you can have one key
per NCBI account if you need multiple
keys you need to make multiple NCBI
accounts how do you use it it's pretty
simple in all the utilities there's a
parameter called API underscore key2
simply assign your key to that parameter
but that parameter and all of your
different requests and you're done
that's all you have to do if you're an
eager echt user there is an
environmental variable named NCBI API
key I have shown on the screen there you
can simply set that environmental
variable to your key and you're done you
don't have to do anything else a direct
will be intelligent and insert your key
into all of the requests that it makes
on your behalf if you don't like your
key you think someone's stolen it if
whatever the issue you can replace it
but just remember that if you do that
your old key is immediately deactivated
and so there's no chance of you having
more than one key on account at any
particular time so what's available to
you now to test these is what we're
calling the sandbox and the sandbox has
the URL that you see on the screen API
dot ncbi dot and limpa energy code / EU
tones so if you use this sandbox you
will find that your keys are always
active and so they are active in the way
that they will be
they are fully in production so this is
a great way to test you know the way
your keys are acting how your software
is managing the keys and also managing
any responses error responses that they
receive from the keys simply placed a
couple of example URLs at the bottom of
the screen there
it's API got NCBI et cetera slash Yuto
/e search for example or /e fetch that's
all you have to do and provide your API
key and you're running on the sandbox
that's available to you now it's been
available for the last couple of months
please use that as you want to test so
just to confirm what actually is
happening now because I know this can be
a little confusing here's a basic
summary so if you're in the API domain
so that is the sandbox if you don't have
a key included in your request then your
current rate limit is three requests per
second for an IP address because you
don't have a key right there's no key in
the request what happens is it looks at
the IP address and if any IP address is
giving us more than three requests per
second then that IP address will receive
a status 429 error if you're in the
sandbox and have a key in your request
and you include the key in the URL then
your rate limit will be whatever value
is assigned to that key now the default
value is ten requests per second so if
you don't do anything you'll get a limit
of ten but if you have negotiated a
higher limit with us and you as I've
shown you on the screen there you can
write to us at info at NCBI to negotiate
a higher rate than ten then that higher
rate is what you should observe on the
sandbox so if we've negotiated with you
20 or 30 or whatever it is that's the
rate that you should see what's
happening on production basically there
are no limits that are key based on
production at all whether you are using
a key or not all right so you can
include your key in production requests
but they're not
functional at all at this point so
production has no effective limits based
on keys the sandbox does and the basic
idea is that when we go into full
production the behavior of the sandbox
now transfers to full production so
again IP addresses without keys will
have a limit of three requests per
second there is a key present then you
get the assign rate limit and again the
default is 10 so again just another way
of reviewing this if you don't have a
key in the sandbox any IP that post more
than 3 requests per second will receive
a status 429 error if you have a key
all right then by default it's ten
requests per second all right for that
key keep in mind it's any activity
around that key so you have multiple
people using the same key it's the sum
of all of that activity has to be below
your rate limit so you've got five
people five machines using the same key
then the sum of their activity together
has to be no more than your rate limit
again the default is 10 and we measure
that rate in one second windows so it's
a one-second moving window and it is not
a blockage it is not permanent service
is restored immediately whenever the the
amount of traffic coming in falls below
the rate limit so there's no action that
you need to take if you receive an error
you should have service restored
immediately once the rate falls below
the limit all right so what are we going
to be doing soon right so we are going
to be setting up some testing periods
where the behavior on sandbox will
transfer to production for one hour
we're going to be announcing them on
utilities announced we're going to be
announcing them on social media the
insights blog etc it already has been a
blog post that I will show you at the
end of the webinar where you can look at
these and when these periods will be it
during these 1 hour periods the behavior
production will be like what it will be
under full release conditions
so exactly identical to the sandbox so
the money slide is this one I'll just
put this up for a little bit of time so
you can look at it this is when these
test periods will be there are three of
them
the first one is this Saturday September
15th from 6 to 7 p.m. Eastern Daylight
Time I've also put times up for a couple
of other cities around the world just
you get the idea the next period is
September 20th and that's September 25th
times listed 10 a.m. on September 20th
two a.m. on September 25th strategy here
is to try and catch a variety of times
in the 24-hour clock all right in a
variety of different days of the week
and so the point of these is really to
make sure that everyone is aware of this
as much as we possibly can make everyone
aware so for your planning you can
conceive of your software working under
full production conditions during these
one-hour periods so if you have software
that has not been adjusted you know to
accept keys or might go over the limits
this could be a problem right that those
software could receive 429 errors during
that time if rate limits are are
exceeded so again without keys any IP
doing more than three requests per
second will get a 429 error during these
one-hour periods if you have a key
anything that goes above your rate limit
is going to get 429 errors during these
one-hour periods so will be again
announcing these a day or two before
they happen just to remind everyone but
those are the testing periods so full
release is currently scheduled for
December 1st midnight so in December
first all of the sandbox API keys will
become active in production and here's
the point that a couple of people have
asked about if you have keys in the
sandbox now you do not need to request
new keys those keys in the sandbox
simply transfer to production so if you
have keys and you've requested them and
we've negotiated rates with you and
they're in the sandbox and it's
all great you're done they will just
transfer to production you don't need to
do anything they'll just become active
on the 1st of December one final note is
that we would advise everyone to
continue to use the tool and email
parameters or to begin using them if
you're not and these are parameters that
have been available to you for many
years and they're helpful in helping us
identify in one case the software
package which is the tool value that's
being used and also an email contact for
a developer in case we see problematic
activity we would like to get in touch
with you to help understand what might
be going on if there is a problem and so
the value of email excuse me should be a
valid email for a developer who can
actually do something about the software
the value of tool should be the name of
the software package and it's very
possible for you to have multiple keys
for that individual software package so
tool is a way of us clustering a group
of keys together around a particular
software tool if you have questions
about that
I'd like to discuss any issues with that
we'd be happy to do that but those are
useful parameters and we would encourage
you to use them or to continue using
them all right so that's basically it
and I just would like to encourage you
again follow our social media for
announcements of these testing periods
as they come along there is a blog post
that I've linked here it's a second link
there that describes almost everything
that I've just told you including
listing the time some testing periods
including the December first date and
other things to think and be aware of
again you can look at the webinars on
our learn page that's there and
subscribe to utilities announce if you
haven't already we will be posting all
of these announcements to utilities
announced and that's a great place to
get updates on our API is general and
again if you'd like to talk with us in
more detail please write the info ncbi
also if you'd like to negotiate a key a
higher rate key with us or have any
questions about the keys i leave happy
to set up a call with you if that's a
helpful and discuss this further all
right so I'm going to be quiet at this
point I'm going to let Peter and Danny
let us all know what some of your
questions to do yeah hi this is Peter we
have a few questions that I'd like for
Aaron could just sort of weigh in on my
answered a couple of them but we want to
make sure that did you get a chance for
your awesome what is somebody got the
impression or they saw that the sandbox
that it was limited set to 100 instead
of 10 is that just a bug or D are you
aware that there was a temporary bug in
the code where some keys were set to a
hundred they should be set to ten at
this point and that should be either
fixed now in the process of being fixed
so there was a the worst on cases where
the rate limit was 100 mistakenly for
some keys so if you saw that that's
likely what was happening my
understanding is that that problem we
understand the problem we've corrected
it and that should be being pushed out
but contact us if you're having issues
with that or if you just in general if
you are seeing a rate limit or an
apparent rate limit that is not
consistent with what you think it should
be that's likely a problem and please
let us know about that if you see
something okay another question and I
think I know the answer to this but I
want you to confirm that it's true
somebody asked how can you see your key
if you forget it I believe it's visible
in your my NCBI account absolutely so
you just login to your NCBI account go
to that account page and instead of
having a button that says like create a
needs to guide an API key your key will
simply just be displayed there so it's
displayed there all the time so that
shouldn't be an issue
okay and a couple things one it's kind
of interesting question somebody wants
to sort of have the next place sure what
you mean by a testing period and I think
the idea is we want people to try this
to make sure that it what their
workflows will be like and just comment
on that yeah sure a couple of couple of
reasons for having the testing period
one is we would expect that you would
want to make sure that your software
works under the new regime of these API
key
in production and so many of you have
set up your software to hit our sandbox
URLs these testing periods allow you to
have your software hit production URLs
with the keys in place so if it was me I
would be looking forward to those one
hour periods is time to run our software
through the production utilities API
service and load it as you think it
might be loaded and make sure that your
keys are appropriate make sure you're
not getting errors and if you need
higher rates then that might be an
indicator that you need to talk to us
and we can we can adjust but that's
that's the one way you can think about
it the other the other our experience
with other kinds of releases like this
is we're also trying to make sure that
people are aware that something is
happening and just to be frank this is
the way that we can get some people's
attention so there are two two main
goals we're trying to increase awareness
that something's happening we're also
trying to provide an opportunity for
developers to actually have their
software working in production
environment as it will be after December
1st okay there are two questions about
negotiating an increased rate and I know
you said this but can you remind people
how to go about it and what's involved
in other words is there a cost involved
and and what was how do we decide
whether we're gonna give them that or
not no you know we're all in the public
domain here everything is everything is
freely available there's no there's no
increased cost or anything like that
because there is no cost what we what we
look at is the level of activity that
your software is producing and and that
we are seeing so we want to make sure
that the API key rate limit that you
have in place is suitable for the level
of activity that you have and so if it's
more than ten we can help you understand
the amount of activity that we are
seeing from your software so if you have
tool and email in place then we can look
at the activity associated with those
values of tool and email and report back
to you some averages that were seen as
well as like a maximum rate that we're
seeing
over perhaps a month say and we can talk
with you in more detail about your
particular application but we can
provide some limited usage data to you
to let you know what we're seeing
because that what we're seeing is what
we're going to use to establish a rate
limit error for Twentynine so we simply
want to negotiate with you about what
you're seeing what we're seeing what we
think is a reasonable rate
another thing that's happened in some of
these conversations is that we'll
discover together there there might be
other ways that you can as reach the
goals that you have for your software
that's not exactly the engineering that
you have now at the API so there might
be another more efficient way of doing
what you're trying to do we may be able
to explore some alternative solutions
with you that you could try that might
effectively reduce the amount of calls
that you need to make and that's good
for everybody
so it's a it's a conversation so would
you remind them how to begin this
conversation on that so the way you do
that is simply write to info and NCBI
just write us an email and just say what
you'd like to do what your software is
if you have the value of email and tool
please provide those and some contact
information and we'll get back to you
and start a conversation and that eat
that email address is on the slide
that's being displayed right now okay
now a couple of other things one that we
have the two URLs now we have the API
URL and we have the e-utilities URL once
we go to production are we going to read
which one of those are we going to
retain and which one is going to go away
and those kinds of things so the API dot
NCBI URL is only a sandbox and we will
not be making that into any kind of
production URL going forward going
forward the production URLs are not
changing at all so you'll still use you
tools that NCBI the same URLs you have
been using so there are no plans at the
moment to decommission that sandbox but
I suspect at some point after December
1st once we see that everything is
transitioned over correctly we may
decide to decommission the sandbox
because it will no longer be of that
much use let us know though if you'd
like how the sandbox available
we can certainly have that available for
a little bit more time but our
expectation is is that production and
sandbox will be exactly the same
experience from the point of view of the
keys that I know this question has come
up in some other context but the API URL
at this point is not going to be the
production supported URL for the
utilities at this point after December
1st it will remain kind of a test
sandbox ok another one
someone was wondering if it's part if
there's going to be an API for managing
the API keys great question at this
point there is not an API to manage the
keys it's something that has come up in
some conversations the best I can say is
that it's something that we're thinking
about but we don't have any immediate
plan okay and I think this is the last
one that we're going to address somebody
asks basically that they're using the
API key now is that basically being
ignored or is it a problem on their
using it before the test period is over
with their software uses the API key now
I salute you for doing it you're doing
exactly what you should be doing there's
no there's no problem with having the
API key it's basically ignored in
production currently but it's great that
you have it there because now you're
done you don't have to do anything so
that's what we would recommend there's
like once you get your keys once you're
happy with their performance in the
sandbox once you have a rate that you're
comfortable with put them in production
release the code let it go you're ready
for December ok I think that's all the
questions that we can address right now
and certainly if you have additional
questions you can write to us at info at
NCBI NLM NIH govt and we'll have these
questions written up with the answers
that we gave in the webinar and maybe
some additional information that's a
document that only be available in that
materials directory so I think that's
going to be the end of the webinar for
today and we'll see you all next time